is that actually what they're called yes
yes yes
that's how they're called
right
it's their special name here we go larry
oh
did you just see what i i can't believe
what i just had
you dreamed it don't worry about it that
didn't happen
jeez
uh by the way also uh when we play blitz
chess with
each other and
uh
we don't hover we just like play bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang
larry's looking at knight h1 uh
only move king g4 but it's good enough
right uh
christian after knight to h1 yes yes
king g4 is definitely good enough uh he
played it knight to h1 and we're
expecting
well it's always nice to test your
opponent king g4 knight f2 check
draw
so
let's go to christian uh who is with
guests let's go first
thank you guys uh abhimanyu first of all
congratulations on a last round victory
it's always uh good to finish on a
strong note uh how do you feel about the
tournament overall yeah this tournament
of course first of all congratulations
to christopher for winning this event he
played tremendously throughout the whole
event making a lot of good victories
throughout this whole event i feel like
i haven't been playing my best like even
the two games i won against awander and
pedro i mean they weren't the cleanest
games and yeah i i definitely i wasn't
playing my best in the last
two three rounds i've been paying for it
what's uh
the process right now to get over this
let's say unsuccessful tournament to
your standards according to your
standards what's the process right now
so as of now i mean this game this game
i thought okay i mean david i knew that
he was 24.99 if i'm correct he gained
like three points he was 24.96 he needed
one point for to become grandmaster oh
wow so he needed a draw on this game
okay i mean my tournament hasn't been
going so great i mean i was just playing
to go play a game and just try whatever
i can and play my best because
whatever happens happens but if you
don't play your best you just can't
learn anything from the game every
morning you have so many fans all over
the world here in the united states as
well what's next for you my next
tournament is i think it's full cl fall
classic in another two and a half three
months but yeah before that i don't have
anything planned as of now any uh plans
to train are you going to train here in
the united states are you going to be
traveling anywhere what
what are you going to do for the next
couple of months for the next couple of
months yeah definitely i mean
probably take a bit of a time off but
after that of course i'm going to start
preparing serious start preparing for
the next event and yeah
i'll i'll do whatever i can i mean i
need to fix this
i'll be money congratulations on a
strong finish
always a pleasure to see you play here
at the uh at the saint louis
congratulations thank you
to which we add our own on behalf of
dorset and i uh congratulations good
luck much success
in your career again echoing the words
of christian lots and lots of fans and
uh we'll keep our eye on you
yeah fine young man very 12
13
right 13 13 13 yes
exactly young man
and too young he's too young
i know isn't it remarkable i mean at 13
i just was like for